starting this our Houston taxes Tangela
is with us our tank set to tangelo
Angela sorry I have no idea
tangela how can I help thank you thank
you mr. Ramsey for taking my call sure
I'm coming
my husband and I we started on our debt
free journey a couple of months ago
we've been watching your video YouTube
videos and is really trying to get in
the mode of things we even went to
purchase the book the Total Money
Makeover and we've gotten to the point
where we tried which is like a struggle
we we we were scraping to save our
emergency fund by we I was putting money
into it to purchase a employee stock
mm-hmm so we took that out we're able to
use that but then as we look at our
budget it's like we actually need that
to get back to get out the rear we're
always in the rear every month we are
money going out is like it exceeds what
we're bringing in and there's some
things I how have you been covering that
[Music]
have you been going in why the stops
when you got a lot off have you been
going into debt every month yes we're
going to get every month and our problem
is we're trying to figure out how I
watch the videos about the log jam how
you got uploads and things up
we have nothing to sell it's like we're
so excited to get started but we're we
don't know how and it's not because the
income is that combination so what is
your household income okay so a month a
month our broom each month
okay what's your household income a year
the two of you both
82 Oh baby mm and what's the debt do you
have not telling your house 91,000
because we don't own a house we're
renting alright okay and break that
ninety-one down for me how much do you
owe on your car on our car we owe okay
because we have two Cardinal two people
one is we had a accident someone hit us
they totaled out our car so we got a
cheaper car after that wheel 10500 on
that one
and then we're paying the you know we
had the gap insurance but it was the
only place it left us without paying
four thousand four thousand dollars on
that car so now we're 40 offering or
four okay just so you have ten on a car
for on a gap problem from a former car
do you have another car note
no okay the other cars paid for or you
have one car we only have one car you're
paying off the gap we only pay $1.99 a
month we've gotten that down to twenty
four hundred okay
and how much do you own credit cards
credit cards altogether a thousand
dollars okay so what do you got student
loans must be it yes student loans we
offer like fifty one thousand dollars
okay all right that's 6166 what's the
rest of it the rest of its like a lot of
okay so on a furniture bill we have the
only all we've gotten that down now to a
thousand dollars and then the rest of it
is like say a payday loan here old bills
it's like old stuff that we had you're
not paying on right now well we're you
know some of it right some of it is
stuff that had went in credit into
collections and this on our report and
so we gathered it up you know the Adhan
so what we really to pay okay
Michael bills yeah let's do this the
things that you're not currently paying
on let's just set those over the side
and deal with them in a little while
okay and then let's talk about how to do
a budget all right how much is your rent
Irene is thirteen sixty that includes
the water bill good okay so the way
we're gonna do a budget is all the
budget is is I want you to jump on get
the every dollar budget app for your
phone or for your computer it's free
okay it takes about ten minutes to do
your budget that way and the the point
is you're not going to go into debt
every month anymore ever again you're
gonna pay what you can pay if someone
doesn't get paid someone doesn't
paid but for right now first thing is
we're going to balance the budget and
what we're gonna do is take the income
that you have coming in have you stopped
your 401k we just stopped that last week
good and did you get a big tax refund
this year no we got when we got on our
tax refund two thousand dollars back and
then we took that and we put it on our
debt that some debt that we had you
don't want to get a two thousand dollar
tax refund that means you're paying in
two thousand dollars too much out of
your chip say one of you needs to change
your w-4 at payroll and bring that two
thousand dollars home which would be
about a hundred and fifty dollars more a
month coming home so between that and
the 401k coming home now we're starting
to you're not doing it anymore those two
things I'll help you start to get the
budget balanced a little bit now what
you do is you to put your take-home pay
at the top of the page and every dollar
has an assignment and we'll just do it
in order until we run out of money okay
first thing you buy is food and that
does not mean eating out you don't get
to eat out you're broke right you're
cooking at home so we're going to buy
food at the grocery store we're going to
cook and healthier anyway and so an a
lot cheaper so eat eating outs a luxury
so we're going to put food at the top
the second thing we're going to do is
we're going to pay your lights and water
you don't have to pay water it's built
into your rent
the third thing we're going to do is
we're going to pay your rent which
includes your water okay and we're going
right down the list of things that are
most important so already we have eaten
and we have a place to live that's warm
or cool okay so now we look we you know
we've lived to fight another day and
then we're going to take care of the car
payment because we have to have
transportation and then we're going to
take a look around is there anything
else we have to do before we start
paying on these bills and then your
first goal is to try to go down the
bills and pay minimum payments the
stated minimum payment on everything
else you've got a lot of money left over
after I did those things you should see
I think yeah we had we should have we
had we got a lot of foolish things like
see our cell phone bills or our than our
kids they all lose
we'll go get another one we end up
financing that so we say $300 a month on
our cell phone bills we pay I told my
husband this month we need to cut off
cable but he's so worried about the kids
not having any welding they need to be
worried about your kids too your
family's bankrupt and you're spinning
like your atom like you're in Congress
$100 a month for a cell phone bill I
mean I'm a multi-millionaire my cell
phone bills not $300 a month of control
so you guys have got to get in here you
got to start chopping some of the stuff
out and chopping right here speed well
you guys make the decisions but if
you'll spend every dollar on paper on
purpose using that every dollar budget
and both of you agreed to that and quit
it and quit just having these drama
things about each individual thing just
make the list make the money go and when
the money runs out we stop spending you
know and it's done that's what you do so
I think you can pay your minimum
payments on everything here that you're
mentioning if you set the other payments
to the side and then as you pay off that
smallest one if you can find any money
pick up an extra job have a garage sale
find something to sell anything you can
do pay off that smallest one when that
smallest was gonna take that payment any
other money we can squeeze out of this
budget and put it on the next one down I
don't think you've been doing the budget
that way doesn't sound to me like you
have you still sound very out of control
very discombobulated